[Music]
it's YouTube week here on the Rubin
report and my guest today is a musician
a youtuber and a jump cut enthusiast
Chris Raygun
welcome to the Rubin report thanks for
having me man jump cut enthusiast
are you gonna be alright because we're
gonna be doing this we don't jump cut
we don't even cut there's no editing
here yeah you're gonna be alright
I think it should be fine yeah yeah I
got experience you do yeah yeah yeah
letting you know live streams live
that's the same right yeah do you want
to like bounce around the room a little
bit cuz I know you jump cut people you
love I'm far no I'm close no actually
for the little disappointed that I can't
slide in from off camera yeah but uh you
know should be fine okay well most of
our guests stay seated the entire time
gotcha
but I know you've got a lot of nervous
energy you don't got you know a guitar
brought you could've brought your guitar
that's a shame
that's a damn shame you may wonder if
Joe off the skills what are you gonna do
just gonna talk alright I guess so so
we're doing a long-form thing here out
of all the YouTube people that we're
doing you're the only one that's alive
is that weird some ways are like it's
incredibly strange to be live with
someone is very this idea it's very kind
of old-school isn't it is very it's
super surreal being here because like
obviously I watch the show big fan of
this channel so to be sitting here is
really strange
I wouldn't say starstruck but definitely
like confusion
yeah the max well you're being added to
a list of names we're you should be
alongside Sam Harris Chris Rea guys
that's the straight yeah like a world
renowned neuroscientist and I make jump
cuts perfect yeah he's cutting brains
you're cutting video video there you go
alright so for the people that have no
idea who you are
Chris Reagan do we do we want to even
say your real name doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it's Chris Ray Maldonado
there you go there you know what do you
do what is it that you do for people
that we're gonna link you them to some
stuff but what is it that you do on this
internet machine man I'm
make political commentary videos that
focus on the regressive left social
justice warriors but I do it in kind of
a ADHD kind of jump cut comedy infused
way mm-hmm hey I think it's funny my
thing they're funny they're funny doing
cool cool yeah so you do you cover a lot
of the topics that I focus on in a sort
of long-form weight here and I'm
unpacking a lot of stuff with with prose
and you're doing it in sort of a very
easily digestible very shareable way
that the kids seem to like yeah
apparently apparently over 150,000 like
somehow yeah all right so that's what
you do online but before you were an
online person you were you were a person
you're a millennial yeah what does that
mean it means easily offended is what it
means was that offensive Eva the way I
said that you're a millennial did that
seem accusatory should I have issued a
trigger warning or no I'm proud of being
a being a smart one I think at least I
think I'm smart yeah but like no I mean
the whole millennial thing is an
interesting one because I mean obviously
I'm 22 years old I grew up in well I was
born in 1999 1999 that wasn't correct
yeah wow you just had your first error
on your age yeah this is why I cut I
don't know when I was born
yeah we are not gonna cut that out go
cool yeah now like 1993 it was when I
was born so it's like I grew up in the
whole I grew up before the internet was
the thing I grew up into the Internet I
kind of learned how that worked was with
new fresh eyes mm-hmm and I mean the
definition millennial was kind of an
abstract definition I feel like I don't
know how to put it really right well I
guess depending on who you listen to
some people say millennial and they need
sort of the spoiled rich generation that
got everything and it's all connected
and they're all walking around with
iPhones and apps and blah blah blah or
some people say you know this is a
generation that is really into helping
other people and wants to do right by
their man and woman and regardless of
cisgender ISM or any other
offend anybody but it really just
depends which way you want to do who you
listen to yeah yeah I mean some people
use it as a pejorative other people it's
just the definition it's just like hey
you were born at this time you know it
doesn't I don't think that the word
holds that much weight that doesn't
bother me when people say because
obviously I am like I say I'm not a
millennial yeah you just tried to age
yourself into something younger than my
god that was you know what that was yeah
that was very weird how can you describe
grow as someone that now creates stuff
on the internet being someone that grew
up on the Internet
because I remember growing up in a time
before the Internet well he had to go
outside to see people and I remember I
saw the internet meaning pictures on a
computer that were connected to
something else we had some sort of text
thing when I was in high school I guess
I which I don't really remember that
well but I remember sophomore year at
college some guy in my dorm started
screaming because he was on his computer
and saw a Yankee logo and it said the
Yankees beat the Braves or something or
Yankees beat the Royals I think it was
three to two and he's like this is the
Internet or even give the World Wide Web
and I remember thinking this is the
stupidest thing I've ever thought the
internet was relied just thought it was
so stupid like why would anyone care
about this and here we are yeah now it's
the now it's a necessity right yeah but
you grew up on it so there's there's
something well literally different there
in terms of our formative years yeah I
mean I grew up around it like my parents
didn't let me do anything that wasn't
typical of 80's children for a long time
like I like I grew up like hanging out
with my friends at like a park and like
playing stickball and all that and then
like all of a sudden BAM Google so that
was kind of jarring mm-hmm but I think
it's kind of kind of helped me adapt to
change a lot better in a weird way yeah
we played stickball too on Long Island
and it was like what we needed was
literally a stick in a tennis ball we
were good to go for hours a day now it's
like you gotta have a phone and you got
you gotta have an app and the stickball
app and that thing's no good yeah it's
just a sort of it is what you make of it
I guess is the answer is that our
growing up on this I mean for some
people I think it can spoil them I feel
like you thinking like oh I have the
world's collective wealth of knowledge
at my fingertips
but like you know I remember before that
so I really kind of appreciate the the
privilege I know a very word but yeah
we'll get it from the context I've got
that word written down here don't worry
about that I'll good all right so so you
make these videos when did you sort of
wake up to the ideas that you're talking
about because I found out about you I
think it was probably wasn't a
tremendously long time ago I think was
maybe eight or ten months I saw your
video that he did that was the parody of
we didn't start the fire and you were
talking about social justice warriors
and the regressive less and free speech
all the stuff that I loved there were
you actually I was in a clip of it yeah
and I was like oh this guy must this guy
is great he says about me yeah I got was
in it
he was clip I think from our first
episode adora when did you wake up to
just that there was something going on
here that you really wanted to talk
about puh man I mean I
the first Inklings of it happened at
your old network when I because I was a
big fan of The Young Turks I would watch
all the time and I think the first time
I noticed it was during an interview
that I believe Genk had with karyn's
brown hat mm-hmm I remember that being
just like I am surprised that this is
happening because it felt so fake it
felt like a sketch yeah so for the
people that haven't seen that I've seen
it but yeah where I've seen a clip
enough of it before it was about to
vomit but can you describe what happened
so I can't strong if you don't know is
uh she's uh she's a men's rights
activist and she just had an interview
at Jahnke and they were supposed to be a
lovely sit down and ended with drank
basically screaming hey make me good if
you're gonna talk about it you're gonna
talk about you know men's rice Michael
make me a sandwich I believe was a ham
sandwich Oh a ham sandwich
gotcha yeah that was uh that was surreal
to watch I was like alright well this is
going off off the rails but I'll keep
watching and then obviously the thing
with Sam Harris happened in Sam Harris
is one of my heroes I I grew up looking
into Sam Harris a lot Richard Dawkins
Daniel Dennett Christopher Hitchens who
I sincerely miss he would mean every day
it would had a field day with this there
is not a day that goes by that I don't
think I wish I wish hitch and George
Carlin were here exactly you know
because we need them now more than ever
to just lay out some fearless fact
exactly and not that I even agreed with
both of them on everything but just
somebody to have your lessly stake out
their position and and do it in a way
that is clear and and make sense we have
so few people that do that yeah okay so
you were so you were a fan of TYT then
you saw the sort of what we now call the
regressive left you saw these ideas
taking root so what were some of the
examples of how you saw those ideas
I guess telling a men's rights activist
to make you a ham sandwich I guess
that's a pretty good line where there's
some other things going on that you felt
either online or in the real way the big
thing was obviously the gamergate
controversy which was like a huge deal
for me especially because like I'm a
huge gamer I'm a big fan of video games
I grew up around them pretty much
constantly it's like the one constant I
can remember is video games yeah what
was your first system and yes NES was
your first system we were just talking
about it but yeah so you you but it
would NES was old at that point I know
we had a late that's that's why I found
the internet way late our household was
kind of kind of you know not exactly
wealthy right that's funny so you
described even though you were born in
93 you described yourself as sort of a
child of the 80s and now I guess I have
some proof because yeah NES came out it
was 85 I remember Super Mario Brothers
and my buddy John's for the first time
that was my jam though yeah yeah but
like the Contra code for 30 lives oh
it's it's the Konami code it's a oh man
a Bab
breakfast a Bab left right left right up
up up up down down start select start or
something like that
it's been a while Dave up up down down
right left right B a select start that's
if you're playing with two players
naturally you can you can you thank your
part a gamer hey man you make me sick
alright so though it's a gamer game so
what we talk about it a bunch on the
show yeah and I think it's sort of like
the phrase millennial you say the phrase
gamergate it means a lot to different
people
give me the one-minute recap of what
gamergate is and i want you to do it so
that nobody gets angry impossible
requests but I will try yes well too
many gamergate was an event happening in
the gaming community where we found out
a bunch of different things about
collusion and corruption in the gaming
industry specifically the gaming press
and obviously it's small potatoes when
you look at the grand scheme of things
it seems like a very silly kind of thing
to complain about but the reality is
that video games are the biggest
entertainment industry of our time right
now it's a it's bigger than films
it's bigger than music no that's not
saying much yeah but you know it's it's
a tremendous industry in where there's
corruption going on in that industry
especially the form of media that's
reporting on that industry right so
important to take note of it yeah so in
effect it was basically proven that some
of the video game companies were paying
off the magazines that were supposed to
review them or they were putting ads and
magazines that were so you get higher
higher reviews there was also all these
accusations of sexism and homophobia
yeah toe a line you were a misogynist
you were sexist and suddenly like the
people that we have been reading for
like years at this point we're saying
like hey you know you fans who have been
reading us forever you're sexist you're
misogynist probably racist and it was
just like what is happening yeah that
was when I first decided like alright I
feel like saying something yeah so
that's why when I heard about it I
didn't quite understand what it was I
actually did a video saying I don't
really know what gamergate is but I want
to know more and what's cool about it is
that it's such an example I think it
explains so much of what's going on
right now because it was an uprising
from the people the consumers that were
like yes video gaming may not be the
most important thing in the world
a lot of them think it is the most
important thing but they were saying we
are going to stop taking the [ __ ]
from the media that's supposed to be
reporting on the things that we love and
then the response by the gaming media
was to turn on all of you guys and tell
you how awful you were you had the power
it was kind of nuts it was it was
definitely fun because I don't think
they were expecting any retaliation I
don't think they were expecting oh how
you wouldn't expect a group of people
who spent their entire lives acclimating
themselves to challenge not like how you
don't expect those people to retaliate
yeah what do you make of how coordinated
the assault on you guys was like that
the fact that basically a good portion
if not all of them dream gaming press
they all started coming out with the
same articles exactly about how evil all
the gamers were the gamers are dead
articles is what those are cliff anybody
wants to look those up yeah but yeah
they all came out in the same span of 24
hours and it was just like what is going
on it's still it still blows my mind
that it happened but yeah it was pretty
coordinated and it was a it's a constant
thing it was going on in the mainstream
media blew up and I think a large reason
as to why the term social justice
warrior and why that kind of person is
now outed and why people know that that
kind of person exists is because of that
controversy I don't think the term or
the idea of that person would have been
normalized as much without gamergate I
really don't think so all right so the
social justice stuff because as I said
before that's sort of what has brought
this big community that we're both sort
of part of we're not sort of part we are
part of it right yeah whether we like it
or not it's brought us together and
there is this idea now that people are
waking up to why it's wrong so why why
do you think that the social justice
people who I say all the time they have
good intentions many of them there are
regressive people that don't that are
often the leaders of the community but
that the social justice people they have
good intentions but it seems to always
go awry is that fair to say I think so
yeah i think actually more of them have
good intentions then I think you even
you would think I think
because like I don't think anybody
thinks that they're doing a bad thing
you know nobody goes out and says I'm
gonna do a bad thing today it's you know
it's it's just this kind of circular
logic because if they have mm-hmm that
convinces them that hey you know what's
really liberal calling people racist
right yeah I was saying everybody yes
silencing everybody yeah brilliant but
they do that so how do we counter that I
think you've done it through comedy I
guess is the answer yeah yeah I've done
through comedy through music I think
that helps a lot that I think is
actually a really huge thing because
obviously music is catching if you can
make it that way
mm-hmm everybody listens to it if you
can get it shared enough that's a pretty
I think that's a pretty unique way of
sharing that message but I mean all it
takes I think is anybody who's thinking
about these things is to come out and
say something just to make your voice
heard in any capacity you have the
capability to do that now you have the
internet YouTube doesn't charge you to
put videos up you can make your voice
heard on this and I think at some point
it's going to be so many that you just
can't ignore it yeah so is that
ultimately the best way to fight back
not only by making your voice heard but
by encouraging other people to get their
voice heard I mean that's what I've said
this on almost every show now I'm saying
if there were a hundred other people
doing exactly what I do I think that
would be great because we need this
stuff amplified I wish there were more
of us so because you're having
conference you having dialogues with
people and you're not like shutting them
down and that's the big thing is to have
dialogue with dialogues with people who
you might not agree with 100% you might
even be madly disagree with but I think
that might be the best method of
fighting it I think would be to have
those discussions yeah so as someone
that you consider yourself liberal you
were part of the left you were watching
TYT when they were pretty much the only
game in alternative media whatever
that's got to be pretty painful as a
young person to watch something that you
respect that you like just kind of
crumble in front of your face right yeah
yeah I mean thankfully I grew up in in
the Internet era so I'm used to things
coming and going but yeah is that
something that's just inside you now
like because these sites just appear and
everyone's on an app for three days and
then it's gone yeah yeah exactly it's
just do people still use periscope I
think I don't know I wouldn't know and I
couldn't tell you yeah I just used it
once it was gone
that's that but so yeah I mean seeing
the young turk CEO that way was
depressing especially because you know I
respected many of them and to a degree I
still like many of them although I don't
know them personally it was
disappointing but not surprising if that
makes sense yeah because this kind of
thing happens all the time
yeah how do you decide who to trust them
because that's what I think the bigger
issue is you're just deciphering through
the [ __ ] and finding some people in
that you know I have alliances now I
think with people that I disagree with
on huge issues that I've had on this
show but I think our alliance is based
in free speech our alliance is based on
some sort of mutual respect even if we
disagree where I've seen I've lost a lot
of friends on this regressive part
because I see the way they'll all hi
about people all the time and that I
think is a bigger issue than whether we
agree on everything or not you're going
to blatantly lie about what someone says
that's a that's a non-starter not
exactly it's shuts down conversation if
you if you defy especially because so
many these people default to these
really powerful terms like racist sexist
and Islamophobe in all these terms they
default to those and they make those
terms meaningless to the people who
actually have to deal with the actual
definitions of those things right and
I'm thinking like how a liberal how like
not liberal this is yeah it's it's it's
cool being part of a movement though
isn't it like we like we all like sort
of lined up together all over you know
literally all over the world we lined up
on something and it's like this whole
YouTube week that I'm doing most of the
guests have something to do with this
topic you're the only one I'm getting to
sit right across from but like we all
woke up around the same stuff it's
actually very cool yeah no it's
definitely an interesting time to be on
the Internet definitely an interesting
time
be a part of any kind of political
discourse yeah this is a very divisive
time what do you make about how the the
mainstream treats this whole idea you've
done some videos on MTV decoded yeah and
the girl over there mr. Ramsey yeah yeah
I've watched some of her videos and
basically she lays out why social
justice is good right that's is that
fair to say that's sort of main thing
that you took issue with yeah yeah I
mean III criticize them sometimes you
know it's I don't criticize the same
people all the time but they they come
up pretty pretty frequently right so MTV
back in the day was counterculture was
cool and edgy and whatever and now it's
the very entity teaching young people to
kind of shut up about their opinions and
follow the groupthink and all that
that's totally the reverse 1986 MTV it's
really strange to see that I get I guess
it's because the people who were growing
up are now in charge and I guess you
know America in general has been
definitely going more liberal I would
say in the last probably couple decades
so you believe me like socially liberal
like a right yeah yeah I'm more
accepting of like gay rights and all
that stuff and I think the people who
grew up in that time are now obviously
in charge of that in charge of those
companies in charge of those studios so
I think what you're seeing is just that
pretty much and I'm not sure if it's
like oh we'll collude with mainstream
media but I think that's definitely
right like you're not saying it's like a
board meeting with a bunch of guys yeah
it blows my mind but I think that they
think they're doing the right thing so
when you've done videos like the one you
did where you sort of took down decoded
and the nonsense that's in there do you
ever think like man I'm getting myself
involved it's something that's really
big here like I don't feel like dealing
with the blowback I don't feel like if
she now calls me out publicly dealing
with her haters or or that I don't want
to be called a racist or a big
or any of those other buzz hey I don't
care I I think again I think those words
mean little to no they have no punch
yeah they don't mean anything anymore
because I think they've been overused to
the point where it's just like Oh a
racist is anybody who disagrees with
this sect of the population on its on a
completely irrelevant topic right so
like I don't mind the blowback because I
don't I don't find my opinions to be
controversial they seem to be common
sense I think I think I think the real
shame here is that I'm sitting here just
because I have common sense right like
I'm not a genius yes Mari I don't have
an immense amount of degrees but just
the fact that I exhibit some form of
common sense is remarkable enough but I
sit here so just having critical
thinking I mean that's what I show them
just to critically think of things and
not immediately when someone says you
don't like to to assume the worst in
them yeah yeah but it's hard to fight
this back because those words do meaning
they do have power they have power now
you're maybe not meaning to me yeah yeah
they're they definitely have power in in
society I think at large I think if
you're accused of racism you could get
fired I don't know I'm sure I'm sure
that's happened mm-hmm
but to me personally like this is my job
when you have fire me no you can't yeah
so I don't really I'm not worried about
the blowback I'm not worried about
labels just doesn't faze me at all
yeah how do you think it happened that
victim culture became so important
because that's what it man that everyone
is always trying to prove that they're
the biggest victim thus you are actually
more morally right than someone else and
they're as I say there's no end to that
because someone is always then going to
try to put them above you I mean let's
go I have a few theories on that I don't
know how let's well thought out though
they are well this is the place to throw
out there yeah I mean I think we live in
a time that's so not fraught with actual
conflict outside of like you know the
Middle East on that but like as a
millennial growing up I can tell you
life was not difficult
life was never oh hey Chris we're not
gonna eat tonight you know it was never
a big deal like nothing was ever bad
nothing was ever really tremendously
awful and I think growing up in that
environment makes very very small things
seem much more problematic than they
actually are like oh hey you make like
some joke that's like mildly offensive
and suddenly it's the end of the world
because hey you don't know what it's you
don't know what it's like to be in an
actual oppressive situation right so I
think that might be part of it so the so
basically the to use some of their terms
the privilege of growing up in just a
functioning society as you said you know
your family didn't have a ton of money
but you weren't going you weren't
starving but your broader point is that
you didn't grow up in a war zone or
under some hugely oppressive regime or
something like that yeah so that the
little things of oh we said this word to
describe a woman or this adjective to
describe it frankerz and become this
massive thing because you're not dealing
with real problems yep I mean pretty
much I mean the the biggest thing that's
happened recently is is obviously the
gay rights movement and how they've
gotten the right to marry and that
wasn't that was the biggest thing in
like the 60s you had like racial
conflicts and like the 50s you had like
McCarthyism yet all this crazy crazy
[ __ ] going on but now it's in the last
couple years it's been relatively
relaxed you know there's not much that I
can think of that I had a problem with
or that any of my friends had a problem
with and we grew up in blankie honkers
and wasn't exactly like you know high
real estate right yeah but so what would
you say then when people would say well
look at black lives matter right now or
something else that's happening right
now or the trans bathroom issue or some
of this stuff you think that's just a an
outlier in a weird way of a healthy
society I think it's a caricature of an
actual of an actual struggle is what I
think I think I mean I know this is
probably a controversial stance but I
think black lives matter is largely just
kind of I think it's it's an Occupy Wall
Street - it's like this hey this there's
this movement that has some
and ideas that's just been hijacked by
winey winey pay you know about the
wasn't there like a head of black lives
matter who like pretended to be run over
by a car did you see that I don't think
I saw that video but nothing would
surprise me at this point yeah yeah so
like we're there protesting gay pride
parades in Toronto until the gays of
Toronto signed their document basically
elevating black lives matter status
above bad exactly like that's
legitimately insane and it goes to the
heart of all of them oh yeah exactly
you're 100% right yeah I think it's
largely just like people wanting to feel
like they're a part of something so
they've a this is a cause I guess I'll
jump into that yeah and feel like I'm an
activist I'm curious if you had friends
that really buy into this stuff like
that really want to prove that they're
the ultimate victim because it's hard to
be it's hard to maintain friendships
under that guys yeah I don't think I
know anybody like that who's overtly
like that as far as far as I'm aware
yeah there could be but I really doubt
it I haven't noticed any of anything
like that yeah yeah you know so we met
once for coffee before it's only the
second time we've ever done the
in-person thing but we met you you said
to me that you're a liberal and you've
always been a little bro sort of what
you've laid out here but you kind of
hesitated to say you were part of the
left and do you like does that exist to
you anymore I mean I know that this
left/right thing barely makes any sense
anymore and everybody's sort of all over
the place at the moment
but does it have any meaning to you like
what is that you're on the left like
what does that mean the left to me means
I guess just politically Democratic huh
yes but I would have to be what it means
right I can't think of anything else
that was good obviously the right the
right would be more politically
Republican but I think that matters the
least I think what matters most is how
you fall in the vertical axes
whether you're authoritarian or you're a
libertarian member of either of these
two sides because obviously there's the
authoritarian right there's the
authoritarian left and what I see in the
left is the left becoming primarily the
authoritarian left that's Jesse yeah
that that thing that wing of it has just
grown to the point that I think they're
making what they're doing is taking
liberals and they're making defending
liberal values is becoming a
conservative principle that none of us
want to hear that but it is because like
I will go on and defend really really
harmless actions like oh this person
used to use the word that triggered
somebody that's it's just a word don't
don't don't sweat it all right all right
yeah welcome to the hour you're the all
right yeah oh that's what they'll say
about you yeah you remember of the all
right they'll just be like oh you're
conservative then right what no I just
what
yeah you're just you're you're defending
white supremacists because you use the
wrong pronoun a trans person yeah
exactly
oh you uh you create you criticize the
the feminist movement oh you must hate
women yeah so you've done some stuff on
the unfeminist and we've talked about a
lot yeah what's your take on how do you
ever feel like you know for you to talk
about this stuff so you talked about
black lives matter we could talk about
this I'm a little bit we talked about
feminism all these things you are a
heterosexual white man yeah I'm a
straight white man so you're the most
hated of all of these things do you do
you ever think or I guess you don't cuz
you just said you don't care what they
think but do everything you're putting
yourself in a really precarious position
to be hated gonna judge you by the group
enough yeah I mean I like to think I
like to think we're headed in the right
direction I like to think we're changing
for the better
although it might not be to evidence
right now but I think you know I know
that what I'm saying isn't controversial
like I know that I know that what I'm
saying is basic common sense criticizing
feminism is not criticizing women a
movement is a movement and how that
movement acts is it's irrelevant what
the skin color the genders of the
characters are I know that that's not a
controversial stance so if people hate
me for it they can hate me it makes no
difference to me
yeah so when you criticize feminism as
you said you're not criticizing women
you're criticizing a movement that you
feel has started to defend the wrong
principles I think a very simple example
of that would be the
tax in Cologne in Germany on New Year's
wear because it was migrants so thus
meaning Muslims yeah that did most of
the attacks that's what the truth of the
situation was and we saw people on the
left you know screaming about the
Crusades and all the usual histrionics
yeah ethical arguments but so the left
it was the left that was throwing their
mothers and sisters and daughters under
the bus because they consider Muslims
more oppressed than women yeah that
would be your critique of of
I mean yeah my critique of feminism
doesn't lie with the definition because
a lot of people will say like oh just
look at the dictionary definition of it
it means to defend the Equality of women
and it's like that could be the
definition all you want what matters is
the movement in practice and I say this
all the time with ideologies in
particular or movements specifically the
definition of an ideology or the
definition of a movement matters very
little because those ideologies are
inherently evolving things like how I
always like to put it was um
feminism is an ideology born of activism
because like the women's rights movement
was an activist cause they had goals
they had they had policies that they
wanted enacted mm-hm and when those
policies got enacted and when they
achieved their goals the women's rights
movement stops because that's what a
movement does it goes somewhere and then
stops because it's achieved all its
goals or or the opposite maybe it
doesn't the problem when you make an
ideology out of that is that what even
when you achieve your goals
you haven't achieved your goals so you
have to make you have to make stuff up
right you have to make yeah oh hey women
still aren't getting paid equally even
though it's clear that that's not the
case that for the same work that we were
actually good yeah for decades we've
known this yeah that women choose
different jobs that might cause
difference and no but something as
simple as the Equal Pay Act that they
have to know exists mm-hmm but they're
like no no it is it's still there's
still a disparity here and it's all
because men get paid less or women get
paid less for the same job which is not
true right it's false so there's just no
end right like their key is that
inherently the problem with all of these
things is that the
and if you accomplish what you want to
accomplish as you just said you have to
find something new because otherwise you
have to get a new line of work exactly
because a lot of people now are
professional professional like they do
activism full-time you know the this is
their main purpose is to be the
spearhead of whatever movement they're
spearheading right so if you don't have
that to fall back on what are you gonna
do yeah I'm trying to think is there any
movement that evolved you know properly
or correctly or attained its goals and
then saw its main leaders and everything
else like really go out and do something
else or move on or whatever I don't even
know there yeah yeah I can't think of
one there might be I don't know so
that's a good question too good question
yeah so that's the inherent danger I
guess it's like you need to get
something done and then at the same time
you can't give up no it's it's your it's
your bread and butter yeah and you'd
like it just this is specifically with
feminism they like all these like
everything's misogynistic now but
everything under the Sun video games
misogynistic brilliant right Graham I'm
really glad we're having this discussion
right right so I assume as a misogynist
that you are when you play Grand Theft
Auto you only punch women yeah right
yeah of course my god that news report
was amazing there was a new support that
I think ABC did yeah during the whole
gamergate controversy where they were
like hey oh yeah you can beat up a woman
in this game it's like well you could
beat up everybody in that game right you
can entirely it's the most time in this
video game you can imagine it's entirely
a gala terian right in a weird way if
you were playing that game and you were
only beating up men what would that
prove you know to be like nothing it
doesn't matter right you kill droves of
men and in that game and those are men
that you have to kill to progress and
not not a peep
right not a peep so you're saying that
you don't think video games cause what I
do not I think I do think they
desensitize you to violence that
beginning you can handle being exposed
to violence a lot more than somebody who
maybe doesn't play violent video games
but I don't think
because in everything do that I mean you
go watch the purge or you watch that -
yeah I think most most things that are
violent desensitize you to violence I
don't think that necessarily means
you're going to go out and kill a bunch
of people because of it
yeah if you're gonna go out and kill a
bunch of people for no reason your your
as an individual your your kind of not
right yeah so is that the the bigger
issues that we never talk about mental
health really so we're always looking to
go at it's videogames its guns it's this
it's that it's our dialogue it's our you
know whatever yeah when really we have
massive mental health issues and we're
just we just keep looking at these
symptoms that are popping up yeah we
keep looking at we keep looking at the
things that these people do in their
free time and not like their own kind of
like bullying is a huge problem that
they're - right mm-hmm is most of like
the Columbine kids and pretty much every
school sure you can name is like always
like this outcast bullied kind of kid
but then they point to his video games
it's like a course he's playing video
what is he gonna do you're gonna go out
with his buds right of course he's
playing video games and also he gonna do
man yeah so what do you do about that
then if the bullying culture is real now
I would RL okay when I was a kid I was
right in the middle I was like not the
most popular and I was not the biggest
nerd I was like right there and I
remember thinking it was gonna be work
to be with the cool kids so I ended up
hanging out with the Nerds more and we
played video games and yeah toys and
whatever we did night and I had a great
childhood but I remember I was bullied
by the more popular kids and I bullied
kids that were less me it's just like
yeah I can't you can't make kids not do
this no no no no I mean I think in in
cases where like the kids become school
shooters I think I think you might maybe
people should be more open to therapy
maybe sure there's something that needs
to be done I don't know what needs to be
done but it's definitely not banning
video games it's definitely not
censoring opinions but oh man yeah I'm
getting worked out can you argue towards
what would you do about just the idea of
bullying
now you see all these anti-bullying
campaigns I also love now every
celebrity you see them on every talk
show and they're like I was bullied as a
kid and I was like big goddamn deal it's
called grow up if ya never bullied
you're gonna enter a real world one day
and the world was gonna [ __ ] all over it
I am I am a 5 foot 4 adult male and I've
always been man we're smaller than I
thought I wanted yeah yeah I've always
been short there always been a Ben
Shapiro you know and you know you get
bullied and I honestly I'm thankful for
that yeah honestly a weird way I know
but can you explain that because I do
see legitimacy in that I'm genuinely
thankful for the for the for like
experiencing that because it's like
again a first-world life in the 1990s in
the early 2000s is really cozy and it
helps to have it helps to have that bit
of character building because I don't
like if I wasn't bullied I don't think
I'd be like I don't think I'd be so
outspoken about this particular thing
because I don't think I would have
gained confidence otherwise all right so
let's do a little election stuff here
because we're talking about sort of
issues in the big sense you know free
speech feminism Islamophobia or you want
to hit a llama phobia first because
you've been pretty critical of the
people that throw that
oh man I'm out there I think Islam is
the most thing that I get ya backlash
for that's definitely the biggest thing
because for some reason it's still super
protected well like again I'm 1/8 I'm an
atheist I criticize pretty much
everything everything that isn't every
religion that's Under the Sun he is
obviously false it's gonna be fair would
you I hear Old Testament what do you
think of it one word one word Oh fake ok
New Testament false Quran it's okay that
was very clever but that's not gonna
save you
yeah so you get you get extra hate for
that because yeah and be on the top of
the oppression Olympics yeah absolutely
I mean especially with all the stuff
that's happened to Sam Harris to and
just in the last year or so yeah it's
been crazy but is that one of the
examples the Sam thing I now use it as a
good example of what good can come from
bad actions because so many of us woke
up yeah now related to that that it's
Oh by doing something so patently
obviously dishonest and the smear
campaign against him
you got a gajillion people to wake up
and now do the videos that you do do
what I do do what plenty of other people
yeah have on YouTube weaker doing and I
was definitely a blessing in a weird way
to describe it I know that says he
probably wouldn't appreciate that no no
probably not yeah but it was definitely
like one of those things where it's like
this is terrible
yeah but it definitely had a good ripple
effect I think yeah so when you
criticize Islam you're criticizing an
idea much like you said before you're
criticizing absolute feminism doesn't
mean you're criticizing all women but
people just can't seem to wrap their
heads around that
yeah and it's it's difficult for people
to understand for whatever reason to me
it's it's pretty straightforward it's
like hey cancer is bad oh you hate
cancer patients good it's a it seems
relatively obvious to anybody I think
with even a modicum of common sense yeah
that what you're criticizing is the
ideas that people employ not that not
necessarily the people who believe these
things in any given capacity obviously
the the the extremists are people that I
don't have a problem criticizing yeah
but I've got a little pushback on that
lately where I keep because I've made
that distinction over and over and over
again
and I know the people who are gonna hate
me for it hate me no matter what but but
I think some smart people and people
that I think are with decent intentions
actually will say to me you know you
can't keep separating the ideology from
the believer even if the believer isn't
going out and beheading someone or
shooting someone or throwing gay off the
crane or something that you still have
to criticize the people do you do you
think that there's some legitimacy into
that not not leaning they have to
criticize every Muslim person saying
well you wouldn't criticize every
Christian man I think there's a there's
validity to it I mean obviously you have
to criticize I think it comes down to
criticizing individuals like oh like
what's his name Reza criticized like
that's a person that you can criticize
yeah because he's a person with a
specific set of beliefs that you know
that those are those are
beliefs yeah it's not just the
generalization I think the the the thing
to avoid is generalizations right but
right I never criticized its residence
Muslim I criticizing because a [ __ ]
idiot yeah very distinct he's a liar I
mean that's why I criticize him not
because I don't care what his religion
is do whatever they want in your own
home yeah it's a shame that that will
get you branded and Islamophobe yeah
alright enough about that let's do a
little election stuff before I wrap up
here because all of this is wrapped
around it now what's happening oh you
know we could talk about the gamergate
stuff the free speech is up all this
stuff has led us to this bonkers
election now we're in the middle of
press yeah yeah what do you make of this
I think it's hysterical I think it's
gonna give me a lot of material that's
what I that's what I think when I was so
bad for the country good for you perfect
man I don't know cuz to me it seems that
there's a very heavy behind-the-scenes
kind of thing when you're talking about
the presidency like I'm one of those
people who believes like if if Donald
Trump gets elected I don't know if it's
gonna be terrible because I still feel
like there's a bunch of people behind
the president who are working in tandem
with or without him to make policies and
to do the basic presidential stuff you
know so to me I'm not even sure if it
really matters which one wins so how do
you as a liberal this is what I have
struggled with now as a liberal when you
talk about all the social justice stuff
Trump is hitting some of the things that
we care about most yeah he's he's
calling out the social justice [ __ ]
he's talking about free speech and the
overuse of racism and bigotry and all
that stuff so he's hitting some of the
most important things but I know he's
not he's not a real liberal so it would
make me hard to support him and at the
same time I think I think Hillary is
pretty crappy yeah yeah yes are you are
you going Gary Johnson if I vote I will
definitely vote a third party I will I'm
not putting a vote for Hillary not
putting a vote for Trump not even mainly
because I just think Hillary's a corrupt
crooked individual and Trump just it
doesn't seem like he knows what he's
doing
to me mm-hmm that's what it seems like
yeah so I don't feel comfortable putting
my vote because that a lot of people say
like oh hey you know if you don't vote
can't complain
and to me it's like that doesn't make
any sense does my get it that's like
that's like if if a boss hired a garbage
employee and said hey you can't complain
cuz you didn't hire him I complain way
more than you can I mean I would always
prefer that everyone vote but George
Carlin did a pretty great bid on why not
voting gives him here like two brilliant
men and yeah true yeah but yeah yeah I
don't know the whole election this time
is definitely like a wake up call
like this is hilarious right it's
hilarious to watch do you like seeing
all the internet stuff get into the
election like as someone that was in it
early with the game you know Pepe the
Frog top tech and blah blah blah you
like seeing all I said get up there like
it's hard to believe that's what when I
saw the Hillary thing and mentioning
Breitbart and referencing my low
articles I was like God you idiot you
just gave them exactly what they wanted
you know not just indeed yeah it's
amazing to see that especially during
that speech when it's just yelled out
like what this is this whole thing is
it's turned into an Internet chat room
right we're half between like a
theocracy and pumped that's where we are
right now I would say so definitely
closer to any accuracy definitely clean
street I knew that it was going to be a
documentary items yes tell me that all
right final question for ya mm-hmm what
does the future hold for Chris Raygun oh
man I mean hopefully I get to keep doing
what I'm doing I don't like to stay the
same for too long I like to mix things
up a little bit I like to experiment
with different formats and different
subjects yeah so hopefully this social
justice train doesn't last too long
because you know you can get jaded from
this kind of thing really hmm you know
how do you not how do you not actually
it's exhausting when you're fighting
people with bad intentions who you know
we're gonna lie about you with the same
arguments because it's like they never
have a different arguments always the
same thing yeah
so how do you not get jaded with in all
that it helps to just kind of for me
personally this is an advice that I can
really give to anybody else but for me
it helps to just do something really
weird
in the meantime like make it make
something that doesn't make any sense
like I have a second channel they just
put garbage on and that helps like okay
I've made something that isn't about
this right but I still love talking
about it and as long as I want to as
long as I like talking about it and as
long as I have something to say about it
I'll keep saying I'll keep saying what I
need to say yeah all right man we did it
live no jump cuts we Came we did it live
we did it level elastic yeah we look we
did it and you feel all right no jump
cuts it was just a human conversation
yeah no we're not airing into a screen
all good yeah no but perfect I would say
all right well on that note I want to
thank Chris raygun for joining me today
and you can check out his YouTube
channel at youtube.com slash see / chris
regan we got to get that fish yeah yeah
that's that's embarrassed I mean I bring
you on as a youtuber you got a slash
there that's how you distinguish the
professionals
[Music]
you